mientras continúan los esfuerzos de
rescate y recuperación El dolor la ira y
la confusión dominan la comunidad de
morby
el puente estaba muy lleno cerca de 400
personas estaban en él
tenías que comprar un boleto para ir a
este puente a esta trampa mortal la
gente pagaba dinero para morir
el domingo mientras la gente celebraba
el año nuevo gusarati una pasarela
suspendida recientemente renovada se
derrumbó matando a más de 100 personas
que estaban sobre ella entre ellos
decenas en niños la estructura de 150
años reabrió hacia apenas tres días
después de siete meses de renovación una
empresa local llamada oreva conocida por
sus relojes y bicicletas eléctricas
llevó a cabo las obras se Está
realizando una investigación para
determinar la causa de la catástrofe sin
embargo el municipio de morbi dijo que
nunca fue emitido un certificado de
seguridad para el puente los Testigos
dijeron que la estructura estaba
demasiado llena y que las fuerzas de
seguridad no lograron controlar a la
multitud actualmente nueve personas
relacionadas con la empresa han sido
arrestadas cargos de homicidio culposo
se les acusa de vender demasiados pases
lo que resultó en el colapso del
congestionado puente
en este momento de duelo el gobierno
está en lo posible con las familias que
han sufrido
la tragedia se produce en medio de una
campaña electoral el estado natal y
bastión del Primer Ministro narendra
móvil la oposición acusa al bjp de
guyarat el partido del Primer Ministro
de negligencia el líder acudió al lugar
de la tragedia y rindió homenaje a las
víctimas